it was an unusual outbreak of chaos in
dhaka
opposition supporters facing off against
riot police
the commotion brought business to a halt
in the heart of the city
and it all revolved around one man
we are here to support our leader usman
but above all to fight for democracy
for freedom for equality for the rule of
law
forever we've been fighting
we are here to accompany usmansonko but
we say no to violence
they're firing tear gas bombs at the
people they want us to react
but we won't do it we'll always be there
for usmansonko
no to dictatorship he's popular among
senegal's young people
usmansonko a former tax specialist is
the biggest rival to president mackie
sal
but last month an employee of a beauty
salon accused him of rape
sonko denies the charges and says the
government is instigating a plot against
him
on wednesday supporters joined the
opposition convoy on the way to court
for the hearing
before they were stopped sunkel's lawyer
says police arrested him for
participating in unauthorized
demonstrations
mr sunko has not committed any act with
a view to disturbing public order
he wanted to defer to the summons of
justice
and you are all witnesses to that
the drama presents an additional
challenge for a man who's seen as a
rising political star in senegal
one of west africa's more stable
democracies
and i'm now joined by journalist samba
bhaji he is editor of africa check
in the dakar bureau good to see you
welcome to the program
samba what are the circumstances
surrounding usman songko's arrest
so sonko was someone before the
investigating judge for
his first hearing following
accusations of rape but on
his road his car was blocked by security
forces
who asked him to change his route to
avoid the crowds of
his supporters who were mobilized
outside to follow him to the court
but when sonko insisted that he will not
change his road
the security forces pulled him out of
his
vehicle to inform him that he was under
arrest for
disturbing public order why do usman
songko supporters insist that the rape
accusation he's facing
is politically motivated
because it happens that the owner of the
massage parlor did
different interviews when the accusation
broke to
states that she does not believe that
there was
a rape uh moreover assange supporters
believe
that there is a conspiracy because uh
sanko
because sanko is seen today as the main
opponent
of makissan's regime he came third in
the last presidential election in 2019
and since the candidate who
came second joining makisel camp sanko
is de facto the number one opponent
and then some coin supporters accuse
the regime of wanting to eliminate an
important
opponent before the next election as
they did with the son of
the former president abdullah and the
former mayor
of dhaka khalifa the both was sent to
prison
a few years ago how much of a threat
is usman's sonko to president mahisao
yeah i mean sanka is considered as
a big threat because uh right now he's
seen
as the only one in the opposition
because
there is a lot of grievances in the
country people are getting more and more
angry and criticizing the way
uh the the country is managed by makissa
and all those people are now turning to
sanko because
uh there is no other opponent uh
apart from uh because after after the
the last election in 2019 uh
many of the candidates or
some politician was in the opposition
has joined
marcus uh marquis alcamp
and now sanko is seen by many
uh senegalese that have many grievances
against the government
as the only one that can uh
listen to them and that can be the real
opposite in the country
right that's samba bhaji speaking to us
from dakar thank you
you